they were first marketed to help smokers
quit for good
now they seemed to be marketed to
Children both illegal and harmful and
parents are concerned I was really upset
I just felt like he'd just ended up
doing something far too young that was
going to be far too it would have too
much impact on him and I do feel that he
wouldn't have gone out that summer and
gone oh do you know what I'm going to
try smoking I don't think he would have
done that I think it was just so easy to
access the Vape products
recent and if data suggests that vaping
among children is on the rise
with one in 10 Secondary School pupils
admitting to having a habit and it's no
surprise why disposable Vapes are cheap
come in child-friendly flavors and are
easy to obtain especially kids who look
older year 11s year 10s to sort of say
oh yeah I can buy them I'm that age or
just sometimes they don't even get
checked for it so it's sort of ease of
buying them is sort of a reason why
they're in such Mass demand at the
moment I think
to stop demand the government intends to
crack down on Supply announcing a new
illicit Vapes enforcement Squad clamping
down on underage sales
an initiative welcomed by David Lawson
who tests these products for a living
and is worried that many don't even meet
UK standards greater checking perhaps at
the border when the products are coming
in maybe the most effective thing to
stop the product getting into the market
in the first place enforcing maybe when
it's on the shelf on the Shelf so
educating retailers perhaps with
training standards working with the
retailers to educate them as to how to
identify products which might not be
lawful and perhaps also the consumers
that they're aware of the potential
products which they should maybe be
buying and the process they shouldn't be
buying there's some clear telltales
from sweet shops to
ticket for adults it should remain an
alternative to smoking it should never
be made attractive or sold to children
Freeman Powell Sky News